boa noite a todos
quando eu fui convidada para participar
desse evento
eu comecei a pensar qual assunto que eu
poderia conversar aqui com vocês e fosse
realmente desafiador
a medicina ela evoluiu muito nos últimos
anos tanto no setor de diagnóstico como
na área de tratamento e hoje nós temos a
redução da incidência de diversas
doenças e doenças que quando jack
diagnosticadas antigamente eram
consideradas uma sentença de morte
hoje elas são possíveis de tratamento e
também um tratamento com uma melhora da
qualidade de vida do paciente como é o
que acontece com o caso dos pacientes
portadores de hiv
já a obesidade ela continua sendo um
desafio para nós e por isso eu resolvi
trazer esse tema pra conversar com vocês
hoje nós vivemos um aumento no número
dos casos de obesidade alarmante ea
organização mundial de saúde ela
considera que nós estamos vivendo uma
epidemia global do diabetes cup da
obesidade
se nós observarmos os nossos
antepassados
eles necessitavam caçar e lutar para
conseguir seus próprios alimentos
além disso era necessário um grande
deslocamento para eles conseguirem um
ambiente seguro para sobreviver
isso fazia com que eles gastassem uma
quantidade de energia muito grande com a
evolução do homo sapiens com a
modernização e com o processo de
globalização
hoje nós temos diversas facilidades no
nosso dia a dia que fizeram com que nós
diminuíssemos o consumo de energia
hoje nós utilizamos carro para nos
locomover
usamos é celulares que fazem com que a
gente consegue consiga se comunicar sem
sair do lugar
temos é controle remotos fast foods de
livres que faz com que nós conseguimos
consigamos ter acesso ao nosso alimento
de uma forma rápida prática e sem
deslocamento
com isso o que aconteceu nós gastamos
menos energia que consumimos alimentos
muito mais calóricos ricos em gorduras e
açúcar
se nós olharmos desculpe se pode voltar
pra mim mas não se nós olharmos aqui
para nossa manutenção do peso que é
necessário que o consumo energético seja
exatamente igual ao gasto se nós estamos
hoje em dia com o processo de
modernização consumindo mais energia e
gastando menos
isso vai resultar no que não consta um
aumento tanto de gordura esse excesso de
energia ele vai ser depositado na forma
de gordura e com isso consequentemente
nós vamos ter um aumento de peso e um
aumento no número de casos de obesidade
eu sei que essa forma de nos explicarmos
como a obesidade se desenvolve uma se
desenvolve uma forma muito simplista
existem diversos outros fatores que
estão implicados na ocorrência da
obesidade como por exemplo a genética
mas a genética é responsável apenas por
5% dos casos fatores ambientais fatores
emocionais e diversos outros fatores que
a medicina vem estudando ultimamente mas
o que realmente tem sido estudar e
comprovado que modificou pois com a
consubstancialmente nas últimas décadas
foi um aumento nos casos de sedentarismo
e uma forma de alimentação inadequada
que fez com que resultasse num aumento
na incidência da obesidade
junto com isso também tem aumentado a
incidência de outras doenças doenças em
que a obesidade é um fator de risco onde
nós temos também o diabetes mellitus
tipo 2 e as doenças cardiovasculares
entre outras que vão trazer como uma
consequência uma piora na qualidade de
vida e um aumento da morbimortalidade de
uma pessoa obesa
esse é um mapa mundial da obesidade
então todos esses países onde nós temos
a cor mais escura o vermelho laranja são
os países onde existe uma incidência que
está acima de 20%
então é esse aumento da obesidade ele
ocorreu em todos os países sejam eles
desenvolvidos ou em desenvolvimento e
hoje a organização mundial de saúde
considera que nós temos dois bilhões de
pessoas em todo mundo com sobrepeso e
desses 600 milhões já atingem nível de
obesidade e se nós observarmos os
estados unidos que é o país que é
considerado o país mais o peso do mundo
essa incidência de 30% acima de 30%
o nosso país não está muito
longe dos estados unidos já estamos
alcançando ele a incidência da obesidade
triplicou nos últimos 30 anos no brasil
hoje 54 por cento da nossa população
adulta já é considerada com sobrepeso e
20% têm obesidade como eu falei
anteriormente a obesidade é um fator de
risco para doenças como diabetes e
doenças cardiovasculares
e essas doenças são a principal causa de
morte não acidental no nosso país uma em
ocorre uma morte a cada 40 segundos
decorrente do em de doenças
cardiovasculares
o que significa que nesses 18 minutos
que eu tenho pra conversar com vocês 27
pessoas irão morrer por doença
cardiovascular ea obesidade é um dos
fatores que traz essa complicação
o que mudou nesse processo da nossa
alimentação com s com a modernização
nós consumimos hoje produtos altamente
processados ou outra processados
esses produtos eles são ricos em
gorduras e calorias conservantes e tem
um baixo é valor em relação à nutrientes
uma em cada
desculpe uma em cada três adultos
consome frutas e hortaliças em cinco
dias da semana
nós diminuímos o consumo de fibras em
nosso dia a dia e uma em cada seis
pessoas adultas consomem refrigerantes
ou sucos artificiais em cinco dias ou
mais da semana ou seja esses produtos
eles têm alto teor de açúcar e poucos
nutrientes além disso dessa mudança no
padrão alimentar com consumo maior de
calorias gorduras e açúcares
nós nos tornamos mais sedentárias nossa
correria do dia a dia muitas pessoas não
conseguem colocar um horário pra fazer
alguma atividade física seja ela enfim o
que for
e qual foi a conseqüência de tudo isso
com essas escolhas ruins nem o aumento
desses desses produtos outros
processados
nós nos ter tornamos pessoas obesas não
associado o sedentarismo bom alimentação
inadequada o aumento da obesidade
aconteceu de uma forma global
hoje a organização mundial da saúde
considera que um em cada dez pessoas têm
obesidade e o que nós podemos fazer para
mudar esse cenário já que a medicina
evoluiu tanto nós temos que chegar num
momento em que essa evolução também
atinja esse tratamento da obesidade
se nós formos avaliar
existem diversas e diversos tipos de
dieta
toda pessoa tem algum grau de excesso de
peso em algum momento da vida
já fez alguma dieta e muitos já fizeram
várias de se nós jogarmos né
consultarmos o doutor google que é um
dos médicos mais consultados hoje em dia
e e utilizar o termo dietas para
emagrecer nós vamos ter como resultado
dez milhões e 400 mil páginas
então a cada dia surgem novas dietas é
dietas inovadoras dietas que prometem
resultados que vão ser milagrosos
associado a essas dietas milagrosas hoje
em dia nós também temos uma mudança nos
padrões de beleza com o decorrer dos
anos em que a mídia nos impõe padrões de
beleza que são praticamente inatingíveis
as pessoas têm que ser eles dias
extremamente magras e definidas o que
isso faz isso gera nas pessoas
insatisfação com o próprio corpo
constante e o que vai fazer com que
essas pessoas tentem a qualquer custo
atinge esse padrão de beleza que é
imposto pela mídia
então essa é buscar resultado a qualquer
custo vai trazer fazer com que as
pessoas muitas vezes não comprometam a
sua saúde e isso não vai ter um
resultado que vai ser duradoura
nós chegamos num momento em que nós
precisamos atingir um ponto de
equilíbrio
então o equilíbrio é fazer o que nós não
precisamos mais de dieta não é a dieta
que vai fazer com que essa epidemia da
obesidade se reduza o que nós precisamos
é de atitude
as pessoas precisam mudar os hábitos vão
mudar o hábito significa você ter
escolhas que realmente você vai levar
para o resto da sua vida
não vamos ter escolhas saudáveis na
nossa alimentação vamos incluir alguma
mudança de hábito que nós vamos
realmente incorporar no nosso dia a dia
e levar adiante na nossa vida
nós estamos num caminho em que não tem
mais volta nós vamos ter que decidir
qual vai ser o nosso rumo pra que lado
nós vamos nos virar
então pra nós realmente temos um
resultado em combater essa epidemia da
obesidade
nós temos que optar pelo caminho da
alimentação saudável
não vamos voltar lá atrás em consumir
produtos - processados buscar alimentos
que sejam ricos em fibras seja na forma
de frutas legumes verduras grãos e
diminuir o consumo desses ultra
processados ricos em gorduras e açúcar e
também procurar a prática de alguma
atividade física seja ela qual for
desde que você mesmo que você não tenha
tempo você pegue apenas a bicicleta para
ir a sua casa
o trabalho você já está fazendo alguma
atividade física e isso vai trazer algum
resultado no seu dia a dia
então eu realmente tenho convicção de
que as mudanças de hábito é que vão
interferir nesse processo
se nós tivermos um hábito de prática
diária de atividade física associada a
essa alimentação mais saudável com
certeza é naquelas naquela naquela
equação em que o gasto calórico
associado a um consumo menor de energia
vai resultar numa redução de peso e
dessa forma assim nós vamos ter uma
redução de peso e vai ser saudável e não
só a redução que se nós levarmos isso
para a nossa vida nós vamos ter também a
manutenção do peso saudável e
combatermos a epidemia da obesidade no
nosso mundo gostaria de agradecer a
participação aqui e deixe essa mensagem
pra vocês né que mais do que uma dieta
seja uma dieta qualquer e surgem na moda
ea gente precisa realmente é ter
mudanças nos nossos hábitos
obrigado
[Aplausos]